l
entre Disney et l'État
de la Floride, l'heure
est au règlement de compte.
Depuis que Disney a condamné
la loi sur l'éducationt t t t t,
leur communiqué était sans
équivoque :
"Votre loi 'Don't say gay'
doit être supprimée,
et n'aurait jamais dû devenirloe
l'abolir par le biais des
législateurs ou des tribunaux."
La guerre est déclarée,
c'est Mickey Mouse contre
Ron de Sanneneneneneneneneneneni
du même coup vient de signer
une loi qui retire les
privilèges de Disney en Floride.
"Disney est un invité
On le leur a rappelé.
"Ce sont des représailles
contre la liberté d'expression",
lance Anna Eskamani.
la communauté LGBTQ +."
Disney envoie un message très
clair au gouvernement,
nous dit Wesley Davis.
de position de Disney, dit-il,
et j'espère qu'
continuer dans cette voie."
Car la communauté a été touchée
de prèhohohohohomophobie,
car Orlando a été la scène d'une
tuerie visant la communauté gaie
ville en est un tragique rappele
ancienne boîte de nuit surtout
fréquentée par la communauté
gaie qu'un tireur fou a tué
49 personnes. Et la complilililr
venir en aide à la fond
familles des victimes.
Pour beaucoup la nouvelle loi
de Santis, intitulée Le droit
dehohohohohohohohohohohohohohohe
"Don't say gay", "Ne parlez pas
des gais", interdit toute
ou l'identité sexuelle
à l'éiriririririre.
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a é
la loi sur le droit des parents,
se défend en affirmant
qu'elle n'a rien d'homophobe.
"Les enfants ont besoi,,,,,,,,,,
les maths, les scien
Ils n'ont pas besoin d'être
endoctrinés dans des théoriesge"
Pourtant, l'éducation sexuelle
n'est enseignérrrrrrrr
de la sixieme année dans
les écoles publiques en Floride.
"Ils ont crée un faux problème,
dit-elle, ils préten
éliminé un problème qui n'a
jamais existé."
qui se sentent différents?
On est en train de leur di
ce qu'ils ressentent n'est pas
normal
"Nous sommes en guerre pour d d,
lance Randy Fine.
Républicains et démocrates
s'entredéchirent.
Et l'entreprise Disney,
qui a l'habitude d'éviter
retrouve prise entre l'opinion
publique, des politiciens
et ses intérêts d'affaires.
g g g g g g g g g g a écrit
un livre sur la relation entre
Disney et Orlando, "Married to
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t te
attention, dit-il, sa marque dee
qui est une source de faiblesse,
elle doit être à
Randy Fine n'en démord pas,
Disney est allée trop loin.
CaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCaCs
de Floride, dit-il.
au poudre, on s'est rendu compts
que nulle autre entreprise
n'avait, on a réalisé
C'est que Disney est
une société distincte à
L'entreprise contrôle
un territoeseseseseseseseseseses
carrés, appelé Reedy Creek,
près d'Orlando.
dans ce monde dit merveilleuxeae
couleurs mais les juridictions
aussi. Disney assure
les pompiers, la voirie,
rdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdures,
en échange l'entreprise
est exemptée de la plupart
"Je vais vivre plus longtemps
que toi"tetetetetetetetetetetete
caricature.Un bras de fer qui pt
durer un an. Car la révocation
du statut spécvivivivivivivivivr
qu'en juin 2023.